flip the script consciously or not many
people tend to choose paths in life by
following a pre-existing script by
script I mean any expectation or
assumption but how we should act some
scripts and norms are important for
example most of us pay taxes because we
understand the public goods costs money
and because we don't want to go to jail
this is a good script to follow
generally speaking many other scripts
and norms helber exists merely out of
tradition regardless of whether they're
still relevant even were some exists for
no reason whatsoever and when it comes
to careers scripts can be particularly
unhelpful you may be discouraged and the
kind of thinking or actions you need to
find your dream job or career for
example script number one entry level
position should link to junior
management positions you should
eventually become higher management
positions sometimes regardless of the
skills of the employees in question with
the goal being to work your way up to
the c-suite or the corner office number
two everyone has a specific career niche
they should be pigeonholed themselves
into and once you find yours don't
bother trying to expand their break free
of it by exploring other opportunities
skills and roles
script number three if any opportunity
comes your way take it you probably get
this chance only once so don't blow it
skip number for everyone should work 35
to 40 hours a week mostly in the office
usual in the same days and times even
though research shows that this is
largely unproductive schedule for most
people
scripts like these and others that limit
the range of paths you can follow our
outcomes you can achieve are at best
misguided other times they're simply
wrong you can get much better results
from flipping the script and taking an
approach at the opposite of what you may
have heard before when you flip the
script you either update remix or in
some cases turn your traditional advice
on its head this is not about marginal
improvement if your job sucks gaining
the right to take off early one Friday a
month won't make much of a difference if
you're eighty thousand dollars in debt a
four percent raise won't pay off your
creditors you don't need to make small
changes you need to level up flip the
script